as you can see i'm i'm back to my roots
right now i'm in the car where where
everything began
uh actually we're at a farm and we're
about to go buy a christmas tree i'm
looking at horses right now but before i
do that i wanted to um talk to you about
the daily wire and what we're doing at
the daily wire and ask you to join the
fight alongside us um you know as you
know at the daily wire we are
we're we're fighting back um we are
fighting the the federal government
against the vaccine mandate you know
we've got investigative journalism we're
exposing things in the public school
system we were a big factor in the uh in
the virginia race and we've got big
plans for 2022 we've got movies coming
out um we're getting into entertainment
we're you know we're making culture
we're not just commenting on it but
we're doing things we're making culture
and as far as that goes um i can't i
can't i can't say much because it's
pretty top secret but i have been
working on
a major project for the daily wire i
wish i could say more than that because
i'm really excited about it we've
literally been traveling all over the
world for this project and it's going to
make a
it's going to make a huge impact when it
comes out it's going to make a lot of
people it's going to make all the right
people very very angry i can tell you
that
and i can't say anything more than that
but um
daily wire members have made it possible
to do projects like this
and um and this will be released to
daily wire members in the you know early
early next year early in 2022 along with
many other projects
i'm just really excited about where the
company is going but
we want you to be on board you know for
your own sake and and for us it's this
is kind of a team effort so
what we're doing right now this is this
is i think it's the first time we've
ever had a deal like this
50 off memberships
if you go to dailywire.com right now and
um you become a member use code dw50 you
get 50 off the membership this is our
black friday special we've never had a
special like this before
um and uh take advantage of it while you
still have a chance because you don't
want to miss out
you know there's there's two things here
you've got if you're not a daily wire
member in the coming year there's gonna
be a lot of really exciting things
uh that you're gonna miss out on if
you're not a daily wire member but um
also again being a member means that
you're you are actually helping in this
fight against authoritarianism tyranny
leftist insanity of all varieties so
once again go to daily wire become a
member dw 50 50 off do not miss this
deal and just uh watch out because we
have a lot of big stuff big stuff on the
way